foreign
[Music]
here in this video we will estimate the
size of melees and how powerful she is
and also compare her with the other
dragons seen in the series as well as
talk about her importance in the grand
strategy of the dance of the Dragons so
let's get to it guys
firstly let's begin with melee's
backstory often known as the Red Queen
she was a she Dragon written by
princesses Alisa Targaryen and rainy's
Targaryen melee is probably hatched
between 50 to 60 AC which are the years
after aegon's Conquest she had been
living in the dragon pit in King's
Landing having never been ridden before
then princess Alyssa Targaryen claim her
on the year 75 AC and two years later
she put her 9 day old son viserys to her
chest and flew him on melees she did the
same thing with her second son Damon in
81 AC within a fortnight after his birth
and when she died in 84 AC melees was
left without a rider until three years
later when the queen that never was
Princess rainy's Targaryen claimed the
dragon in the year 87 AC and became the
last one to bond with the bees now for
her description the Red Queen has a
magnificent Beast she was first seen
flying alongside sea smoke in the fifth
episode melees does appear to have been
one of the oldest and largest dragons
after vegar herself and was probably one
of the second generation dragons hatched
to The Originals melees has a similar
body shape to Sea smoke but was red in
color has a shorter tail and spots a
crown of large horns on her head melees
had Scarlet scales and pink membranes on
her wings for which she receives her
nickname the Red Queen her Crest horns
and Claws were bright as copper and we
could say that she was one of the
spikiest dragons in the series
so let's get to the estimation of
melee's size this is the Crux of a topic
at hand and we will do our very best by
using a similar method as we did earlier
in estimating the size of drogon vegar
and small so let's take the scene of
melee's up close face to face with aegon
and Allison the cast members were 1.66
meters or 5 feet 5 inches and 1.78
meters or 5 feet 10 inches respectively
so putting the same scale in the same
aspect but sideways on melee's head we
get a measurement of around 10.5 to 11
feet long that's just a head that's a
big head it might not seem that big but
that's because it's horizontal as
compared to the height of these two
characters which are vertical
so now that we have the head measurement
we can now extrapolate it by using the
scale and adjusting it while putting the
head size in mind so as we can see the
head would be around 10.5 feet or 11
feet long and therefore the entire body
measures around 160 feet long or even
more since the tail wasn't straight but
waving around
but just for argument's sake we will
finalize the size of melees at 165 feet
which when converted to the metric
system is 50 meters long her wingspan
would be even more maybe around 1.7
times the length putting her wingspan at
around 280 feet or 85 meters from tip to
tip
so now we come to the bigger question
how big is she compared to drogon vegar
caraxis and the others well if you
haven't seen the video of us estimating
Vega drogon and smart then I suggest you
check it out it's in our Channel
so uh drogon is around 130 feet long or
close to 40 meters which means that
melee is at 50 meters is 25 percent
longer and also since her tail is
shorter with respect to her body length
therefore she is more massive than
Danny's dragon by quite a bit as for
Vega the biggest dragon in the series
she is 240 feet long or 80 feet longer
than melees which is still a big number
but the Red Queen has speed and ferocity
on her side against the very old vegar
now let's talk a bit about how melees is
a powerful and very important asset in
the war to come and why her siding with
the blacks extended the war as well as
prevented Domination by the greens well
the Red Queen was considered one of
westeros's fastest Dragons by 75 AC
easily beating terraxis and vegar in
speed but she had grown in Dolan and
lazy by 129 AC around 50 years later yet
she was still terrifyingly fast when
awakened being of old age as well as big
of size she was wise and experienced in
combat so that is why Queen Alison tried
to negotiate with Princess rhaenys to
join her side since she knew that if the
she Dragon melees was to be on the side
of the blacks there would be quite a bit
of an advantage for princess rhaenera to
get the iron throne
the blacks already have curraxis Cyrax
sea smoke Moon Dancer Eric's Vermax and
probably Verma Thor and Silverwing at
that point of time while the greens only
have three with Vega being the only one
of strategic significance and while
Sunfire is of fighting size he is still
small smaller than Cyrax or even caraxis
and sea smoke the dragon dream fire
while a formidable Beast lacks a
competing writer since Helena is often
lost in her own world and that is why
princess rhaenys was locked in her
Chambers fearing that if she joined the
blacks all hell would be let loose
so now we'll mainly see battle in the
dance and if so with what dragon or
dragons
as of season 1 we will not be seeing her
in action anymore aside from the
breakout from the dragon pit from this
previous episode if the series follows
the book religiously with a few minor
creative Independence which is quite
often seen in any series
so the next season will have melees
facing off against vegar herself and
also against Sunfire with the results of
the battle up to you to find out we
won't be spotting that much so I hope
you have enjoyed watching this video do
hit the like button for support and
subscribe but most of all smash that
Bell icon for regular updates on new
videos right here on this channel till
the next one take care fam